this is insane
this is one of the most thoughtful
people i know let's clap it up for the
legend pharrell
[Applause]
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
what's really exciting is we're teaching
people the next opportunity
you know a lot of things what really has
always attracted me to you is you've
always been more thoughtful outside
yourself i think selflessness is a
superpower and i think when people
actually know how to balance their own
selfish wants and needs because the
humans are human
with also having equal if not more
interest and selflessness
and i think that's a real strength of
yours and i think
the blockchain by nature
is built for a lot of opportunity for
people to help people and makes me happy
[Applause]
[Music]
when i say the word curiosity where does
that take you curiosity is the life
force in all of us the minute that you
stop being curious that's it your life
is over it's actually the active
ingredient to
growth and not necessarily maturity
right because i'm a big kid
i haven't figured out how to grow up yet
and i have four children
and they're looking at me like come on
dad like curiosity is everything it's
the key i agree i said in my opening
keynote i'm gonna push it again
please lean into the things that you
might be curious about but don't know
people are so focused on being
comfortable so many people that lean
introverted came up to me yesterday and
say thank you for pushing on the discord
and twitter and on your opening keynote
i actually made two or three new friends
for real try to lean into places that
are less comfortable or something a
little bit different what you're doing
right now is super amazing
creating this platform for people to
hear great ideas great concepts and to
feel welcome and to feel included for
him to create this space for you guys is
amazing
let's stand up for our guy
there was only one there was only one
made-up character in the friends world
only one the three-horned harpick the
trait of the three-horned heartbreak
is to be thoughtful
this is one of the most thoughtful
people i know let's clap it up for the
legend farrell
[Music]
i know you came to see her but i was
really happy no i didn't even see you
hello how are you how are you doing
have you slept a little a little doing
an amazing job oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
i just want to say that i got on tick
tock because of you because my friend
wouldn't stop sending me your videos
just do it and then now i'm here with
instagram to capture content so
full circle yeah i'm so proud of you oh
thank you
everybody that's what happens when you
actually do instead of talking yourself
out of it in your own brain my hand is
shaking
thank you so much welcome i'm so happy
you're here truly this web 3's only been
around for a hot second we need to be
open-minded to new people coming in and
be kind and be nice to them you guys are
great
thank you gary
just look what you did take a moment
hope you're enjoying it
[Music]
i did
thank you so much
thank you have a great
hey bro you've inspired me to create
grow and do my own i open my own barber
shop because of you i'm an educator now
man like i lost my wife a couple years
ago and you're into your content changed
everything from me
i appreciate you glad you're here
[Music]
i apologize i gotta run so much love you
guys thank you guys
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine i don't know fecon is
changing the landscape but i hope it's
inspiring
curiosity right meaning
i hope other projects that are not even
created and obviously the great ones
that are in the ecosystem are saying
okay there's v-con they did this well
they did this not as well i have a take
on this uh let me take advantage of the
smart contract i mean i think v-con and
v-friends ambition from day one was to
educate through execution i'm incredibly
happy with the sentiment of the first
two days really from people i respect i
feel the sentiment is incredibly good
there's you know obviously just a lot of
excitement around the content but from
the people in it getting the flowers
matters to me i hope it inspires good
executions by other projects my hope is
that people are putting out 2023
versions for themselves that are better
than the one i did this year i have that
same challenge for my own self what or
who inspired the art behind the friends
i i think the biggest you know it's fun
because my mom's in the background in
dover new jersey when we first came to
america i don't know how we got them
because i know we weren't buying stuff
so somebody either gave it to us or we
found it
there was these books called sweet
pickles
that i used to look at a lot
and so between that and then my whole
life my whole life snorks and wuzzles
and transform i'm i'm i'm 46 years old
for us in our mid-40s we got bombarded
with intellectual property like you know
darwin duck and you know and and all
these suit the justice league and batman
and he-man and all this stuff and so
it's just been such a big part of me
what do you feel is missing
in terms of taking a solid step towards
building assault community two very
clear things the reason most people
struggle with building community is
almost everybody who says they're
building a community is actually trying
to build customers they're not trying to
build a community they want them to buy
from this is my community by the way buy
this home for me this is my community
buy this coffee for me
people trying to create customers
building community only looks like one
way you
are giving more to them than you want
from them
and most people can't do that
most people aren't trying to build
communities they're trying to use the
word but if you switch to if you erase
behind the word it actually says
customers
thank you
can you do me one favor my friend
got me this ticket because he shouted me
out every day on your phone
yes you said he was like dylan's awesome
you got to send him he's your biggest
fan can you just say hey to him really
quickly
i'm super upset juicifer
revving khan
we miss you both we married you a lot no
i miss you more is it required i didn't
have [__] recording i'm just sorry
just we're not going to believe this we
just made the best [__] video of all
time and your buddy here did not record
it it was [__] amazing i said that i
loved you more than him and this and
that it was [__] epic and yet it
didn't record so we have this second try
we miss you we can't wait to see you at
2023. i hope you're welcome
oh my gosh
gary honestly
like
this was the greatest experience of my
life i broke all my fears and i got to
connect with seriously there was like 45
people waiting to talk with me and it
was like so meaningful
[Music]
[Applause]
they're trying to make it like we're
done yeah that's it
yes
[Music]
what's up bro how's the econ going
good brother enjoying it
good man thank you for coming
thanks for coming
jacob glad you're here
thank you for coming
hope you're enjoying
it thanks for coming man you enjoying
good
[Applause]
i love you guys
[Laughter]
thanks for having me i'm really glad you
guys thanks for buying thanks for having
us nothing is more interesting for me
than to come to one of your guys
festivals it will happen sooner or later
love it
fellas love you keep doing your thing
how's the response been incredible great
thank you so much what's up my man dude
congrats on all of you guys success
appreciate it it's great to experience a
real
everybody come over here and get a
banana you taking a picture with us
let's go
let's go gary let's go come on jess
i'm really proud of you guys thank you
appreciate that
for a second
hi thank you so much for having me i'm
so happy to have you here thank you so
much proud to be speaking here you're
very sorry i'm wearing you on her
t-shirt yes i am
how's everybody been here
oh my goodness people here just came
to like connect with others and to like
spread the love and get healthy yes so
that's really nice
also this is so collaborative dude we go
in sweep some people's floors put them
in the machine hype up their projects
show everyone everyone's like the whole
community is like this is nuts let's go
anyways that's the car machine we're
going to come hot and heavy to everybody
you want us out bro how's everybody's be
convinced in general good oh my gosh
we've had so much fun
this booth has been nuts
howdy guys so good to see you man
hi everyone
how's your voice my voice is hanging
hanging in there you and i sound about
alike i'm like
how are you i am marvelous thank you for
asking i'm like sucking in caffeine as
fast as i can my sister
oh my god hi
so nice to meet you
many of the vaynerchuks are like like
the most wonderful people on planet
earth so i can already imagine that to
be the case with you as well you are an
absolute gem god bless you and you know
what pulling this conference together
i'm sure this has been something that's
been a dream of yours your entire life
and congratulations on this like finally
coming to fruition that is absolutely
incredible that's special like for real
this is
crazy and seeing her speak earlier man i
was i'm just crying too much what the
hell he's the cry or not because because
you want to know why man like seriously
if people could see
where we came from to where we are now
and everything that's happened like it's
just a dream come true like really i
mean really for real i get it i
regularly call you my angel because you
really truly are so
i love you to [__] i don't know how
you're doing it i love you i love you so
much you good you having fun yeah this
is incredible and i'll tell dave you
said it could be pretty busy i saw dave
yesterday okay great i'm just waiting to
see you yeah thank you how's it going
how's the panda did you hear your pan
already she crushed it killed killed it
thank you she's too kind thank you
logan
i just jumped i just look they can't
even do it i'm more athletic than you
guys
i'm like i'm like logan i should be in
wrestlemania dude where'd you come from
i [__] just jumped these two you
thought it was impressive
i thought you were a stalker i was about
to tackle you how are you i'm well
brother hey bro you know when you were
in puerto rico and you said uh you want
original number five yes and i kind of
like hesitated a little bit yes because
original number five is a picture of you
and i [__] and yeah i swear to god
and i don't know if you heard but i i i
am gifting it to you
on stage i said it
you should have seen him jump this [__]
i [__] wish i saw you through a
hurdle
what's up family my name is nick nice to
meet you nice to meet you bro how are
you doing i'm very well how are you
doing can we take a photo a hundred
percent bro tell them about your problem
so project is called ranches
point one floor
uh
wow if you know blau of course i know
who the [__] do you think you're talking
to bro
here's the reason my stuff sold out so
that about four months ago good for you
double the full price on it with about
150 traded we're creating a game kind of
gambling probably not smart for a 13
year old to make a game like games
whatever it is before i did this i did
like a roblox black market business for
six months what i did is i bought and
sold roblox items roblox doesn't like
when you sell their crap i got shut down
eventually yeah
but you learned yeah flipped my way up
and now i'm here i'm glad you're here
bro you enjoying this yeah goodbye enjoy
it
nice to meet you
you can't but it's the most important
thing let me leave this there i was
gonna give him a break he's got so much
going on wow look at this look at look
at what you and the team dude look at
this
this is insane
wow
looking forward to our thing yeah yeah
that's gonna be super good i got a
picture tomorrow for you yeah
every day tomorrow
i'm really proud of you guys
you guys ready yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you're the man
[Music]
really gracious to invite us out to talk
about what we're what we're building so
just really happy to be here and to be
around all this incredible energy it's
been such a dope thing to see how every
how everyone has been so welcoming and
empathetic and uh man it's such a
reflection of you man so thank you thank
you
on that note
before we go into this
i just want everybody to and i mean
everybody in the stadium
to give each other a round of applause
because i cannot believe how many people
have come up to me to talk about
how you've been to each other and to
them so can we just take eight seconds
to clap it up for each other
seriously
this has just been consistent feedback
all my friends that have flown in for
this are like i just can't believe these
people it is the most humbling for me
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [__] no [__] that's so cool
i like that
[Applause]
come on let's step up we can beat them
you're small the mighty
guys they're much smaller than you come
on
[Applause]
okay guys don't worry just step it up
hard go go very hard
guys they're so much smaller than you
they're much smaller look how small
let's [__] kill them
[Applause]
baby i feel like the man of the year
king of the hill can top of my ship i'm
tired of all of this link up in bill
while all they be doing is [__] i'll be
a cheer just popping my [__] popping the
tab or rolling and still i be on 10
cause there's only one diamond doesn't
much budget for quarterly [__] [__]
everybody who's spewing negativity and
trying to tear down others and their own
insecurity i'm coming for you all this
[__] energy that i've been getting
from all these friends you've got a
problem now i'm a [__] 5.0 version of
myself now i'm a different [__] dude
after all this stuff this shit's been
instilled in me this weekend you have to
understand you're in deep [__]
trouble i'm coming for you i'm
suffocating you i've been putting
pressure on you that's why you're
nervous that's why you've gotten louder
but i'm being really [__] nice right
now when i tell you i'm [__] coming
for you and i'm bringing
optimism down your [__] throat i'm
gonna [__] find you in every corner
i'm gonna get to every single [__]
person on this earth and it's still
proper [__] perspective of actual
love and optimism into their [__]
soul and slowly but surely i'm gonna
hunt down all the [__] negativity in
this [__] universe and i'm gonna
[__] choke you the [__] out i'm being
nice right now i'm being very nice right
now because i'm calmly and i mean calmly
giving you a [__] warning but after
this energy that's coming to my [__]
soul this weekend from all these [__]
people i'm gonna [__] come and get
you i'm gonna [__] come and get you
person by person person by person word
by word word by word and i'm gonna
[__] find you and i'm gonna smoke you
out and i'm gonna push [__]
positivity into your life i'm gonna give
you love actually i'm not coming with
hate for you i'm not countering your
[__] hate chess moves with [__]
hate chess moves i'm coming with
straight love and compassion
the wrong [__] dude with the wrong
[__] skills
got instilled the right [__] [__] and
he's coming for all the [__]
negativity in the world and piece by
piece strategy by strategy decision by
decision execution by execution i'm
gonna [__] get you i [__] see you
i see you hiding in the corners of
twitter and discord and instagram dms
and in the comments i see every one of
you and your cynicism and your
negativity is in deeper trouble than
ever before because i'm more motivated
than ever i'm more focused than ever i'm
stronger than ever and i'm gonna [__]
get you you understand
signed scary [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
good in here
don't forget the eyebrows
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
she said you gonna drink your life away
baby girl i might i can't [__] with
y'all i stay in my lane cause y'all
ain't right be the eyes and remain
humble
my girlfriend's parents she wouldn't be
able to marry me because if they don't
let her marry me
so what are you gonna do what do they
want from you to be in a software
developer and keep earning that money do
that tell them you're gonna do that
marry the daughter and then change your
mind
[Music]
did they see the video
no no oh my god he was mad at me yeah i
get it i get it i get it
[Music]
i'm glad everybody's happy
that has a barrel
thank you for saving my life literally i
brought my superhero with me my mom she
wanted to thank you for saving my life
you literally saved my life you did you
saved his life he was in such a dark
place so thank you brooke thank you
thank you forever
[Music]
thank you
i need you
i need you with the content but
like this stuff it's real i can't put it
it's got to be right
i need your help i need you instead to
go deep
dustin figure out who else just i need
[Music]
is
i'm [__]
hanging in good brother thanks so much
for doing v-con man
absolutely monumental brother thank you
beth yeah thank you everybody did i get
to everybody
yeah
of course thank you brother i appreciate
that take care
take care take care thank you i
appreciate it
love you fellas
we've been talking about this [__] for a
long time and we've been on this for
months secretly working it out with
garyvee they didn't think i was gonna
show up god damn it i'm here
d-o-double
g for the g
the d-o-double-gb
[Laughter]